hey guys Ryan right here I woke up this
morning looking forward to the comments
because I posted three videos like
really late at night not one comment out
of the few hundred was about any of the
videos it was all about this trailer for
some movie called Jurassic world which I
am so [ __ ] excited for by the way I
can't [ __ ] you guys like this movie
looks so [ __ ] cool just from the
images I love Jurassic Park I hear this
is like the reboot in a way or like the
continuation reboot or something I don't
know what they tried to move a
terminator salvation which also has
Bryce Dallas Howard so she is the go-to
girl for Part fours now apparently I
really want to watch this trailer has
Chris Pratt I love Chris Pratt he is
funny and he is cut now he fat boy
anymore he that he ain't that fat baby
might be worth watching she means the
whole Jurassic world to me do you want
watch it with me 1 2 3 I'm really proud
of you for going on this trip you're
gonna have so much fun and remember
something chases you
it's neck
that's Jerry's birthday
we have learned more in the past decade
from genetics than a century of digging
up bones a whole new frontier is opened
up we have our first genetically
modified hybrid Piper's might've made a
new dinosaur probably not a good idea 40
feet high really we should find out
Oh what what kind of dance are they
cooked up in that lab oh
Givi evacuate the island she's a highly
intelligent animal she'll kill anything
that moves
yeah it looks cool I got so much chill
those little dinosaurs were always the
ones I was most scared of as a kid
though the little ones on the line they
could hop onto your crotch easily yeah
okay I'll admit because of the new type
of style they're going for sometimes the
acting look a little cheesy to me yeah
but it's a totally different vibe than
before like it feels more like science
fiction than ever I mean it is a science
fiction story but to have it like really
feel like a sci-fi world in a way is
pretty damn neat to me watching it as a
kid it was terrifying but like now with
the kind of technology they have for
these movies and seeing it on IMAX oh
yeah that'll be [ __ ] terrifying ah
scary just the thought of something that
much bigger than you existing and
standing laid right right I like the
idea how they're taking it with the
theme part being open now in the first
one it was just like oh they're thinking
about opening up the park and now
they're like no we got it down this time
oh no they definitely had to raise the
stakes somehow it's so like science
fiction to go we made a hybrid of this
but at the same time it's like [ __ ] it I
like the new sci-fi world that they've
created with this you know it's
futuristic this time around so it just
sound like something that human beings
would do too I just try to accomplish it
alright let's just [ __ ] with everything
mmm I like how Chris Pratt is redoing
his image with like being these action
badass heroes it has a little bit more
of an action vibe about it you know like
in the beginning of it it did start
bringing back the like wonder of it all
yeah you know like oh yeah I forgot this
is pretty [ __ ] cool to look at before
[ __ ] got crazy it's like beautiful and
it did look like appealing that's a goat
yeah exactly good I kind of want to go
there yeah we would be kinda cool looks
like a legit zoo so yeah I would love to
go to that but then you know the fact
that they amped it up with this like
type of futuristic dinosaur or whatever
I don't know what exactly was going on
when Chris Pratt was on that
recycle and Raptors were running too but
it looked cool it just looks cool like
it doesn't look like Jurassic Park 3 it
looks better
a part of me is a little bit
disappointed that it's only one dinosaur
or it could be that this one dinosaur
turns all of them into vicious killing
machines to you like a vampire bites
every dinosaur they become vicious it
gets scarier where the whole park full
of the Bennis yeah I think it's cool
with the whole park full of dinosaurs
and having the park full of a bunch of
[ __ ] people you know that's pretty
[ __ ] scary because they're gonna
rampage through that well I think what's
gonna happen is like whatever this new
dinosaur is just probably going to do
something that causes like the cage it's
pretty down or something like that you
know then that's something you lose
because the Raptors they show get loose
at the end or I don't know if that was
intentional I don't know if they're like
we gotta use these dinosaurs this
dinosaur imagine epic dinosaur fight
talking like a big monster fight that'd
be [ __ ] sweet like the finale when
that uh see what did what would that
thing because I don't know what kind of
dinosaur that would be whale it was a
whale a dinosaur whale dinosaur whale
that's the technical term the scientists
have given it a sharkus is scary it's a
terrifying being to human and to see one
just hanging there lifeless and all of a
sudden this gigantic thing comes out in
front of all of these people like it's
Shamu or something now that I look back
on the trilogy we haven't really dealt
with like water dinosaurs before to
actually see that was pretty [ __ ]
scary I like that they didn't show the
dinosaur yet eh oh yeah that would be
cool if they do that like for most of
the movie yeah it definitely ups the
anticipation it makes you really you're
like what the [ __ ] does this thing look
like and I hope they don't reveal it I
really hope they don't reveal it and
then we just go into the theater and we
see this terrifying thing you know that
would be pretty [ __ ] cool the
experience they didn't really show too
much of the violence they would just
show a little teeny snippets here and
there yeah it feels different it feels
reinvented and it feels scary again that
was pretty scary actually
despite the cheesiness of it all like
it's not as cheesy as it looks in the
trailer I hope the acting is hopefully
better than it seems that it'll be yeah
something about the acting seemed a
little bit like genre acting to me like
and they were aware of the jabra or
something you know it still looks cool
thanks for watching this with me baby I
didn't want to be in the video anyway
for you to the channel you just wanna be
oh I just didn't think you wanted me to
be that's not sure I thought that you
didn't want to be in the video that's
why we need clear communication if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects veronica
has a channel to actually she does a lot
of covers and blah blah yeah yeah it's
fun it's fun I'm sure they know that
everyone should flock Viper mutt I per
much please give me a shout out I fully
support your channel keep doing what
you're doing
Viper mutt Vipers scared the living [ __ ]
out of me you know you think about
Jurassic world and there used to be like
giant [ __ ] snakes you know having
there still lard but there was like 60
foot snakes back then imagine just being
consumed by a snake and being alive
throughout the whole thing the [ __ ] was
that I don't know she thought the
horrible things you bring up Viper I
hate snakes
pivot kid 85 can I have a shout out and
Iran heard the word pivot I think of
that scene in friends when Ross and
Chandler Rachel were carrying the couch
and Ross was like pivot pivot pivot and
then Chen was like shut up shut up shut
up oh I love it they are they truly are
my friends thanks for the memory pit
weekend
Aaron R Jones please react to Jurassic
world BAM did it on this video
[ __ ] yeah let's all get nasty tonight
also can I please have a shout-out Aaron
R Jones yes you can Jones I'm gonna
assume that he is black which is okay
nothing wrong bean black yes sorry
friend let's go with yours mine doesn't
sound as nice I have black friend named
Aaron Jones but that was in middle
school I knew a black guy named Aaron
he was a dick did you really he's also
an actor yeah I hope he never makes me
you you really mean it I really mean it
I hope you that's you you're an aspiring
actor no you're horrible you're never
gonna make it
hope you're watching this Aaron Jones
the one hook that I know Aaron Jones
anyway
I'm Aaron Jones yeah great name cool
great name and I fully support blacks I
just want to make that clear we both do
we both do we support blacks we love
everyone we donate to a charity to help
procreate more black people you know I
heard they're doing like a hybrid
actually of black people and white
people and there's already children hi
they didn't have adults who are a hybrid
of these two races all right cut it up I
can't